bonjour alexis heureux de vous retrouver
ce matin dans la matinale de rtl france
pour parler de cette primaire populaire
est sans surprise christiane taubira
remporte là remporté donc qu'est ce
qu'on peut retenir de cette consultation
en ligne et de ses résultats
alors cette consultation dont déjà elle
arrive un peu trop tard et c'est ce qui
fait d'ailleurs qu'il n'y a pas de
dynamique d'unité derrière la victoire
de christiane taubira cette investiture
ensuite c'est un fait nouveau c'est le
vote majoritaire c'est à dire qu'on
donne des notes aux candidats en
fonction de si on trouve leur profil
leurs idées passable assez bien bien
très bien christiane taubira a eu bien
plus anne hidalgo a eu passable plus
elle finit 5e derrière pierre
larrouturou donc déjà voir le discrédit
d'anne hidalgo dans ce vote qui a
rassemblé plus de 400 mille quatre cent
soixante mille inscrits et qu environ
400 mille votants 80% qui a voté pour
vous donner une idée d'ordre de grandeur
lors de la primeur du parc la primaire
patron du parti socialiste en 2017
c'était quasiment deux millions de
personnes qui étaient inscrits et benoît
hamon avait gagné avec 1,18 million des
votes donc on n'est pas du tout dans les
mêmes échelles même si aujourd'hui le
nombre de gens inscrits donner une
certaine légitimité à christiane taubira
mais personne ne s'attendait à une autre
victoire que celle de christiane taubira
dans cette primaire a été fait pour
elles par des militants qui étaient
issus de la social démocratie qui
attendaient une nouvelle candidature
pour auxerre en quelque sorte cacher un
peu anny d'algos qui patine dans les
sondages mais proposer un nouvel élan
donc ce qu'il faut en retenir c'est une
candidature à gauche de plus plutôt
qu'une candidature de rassemblement
c'est d'ailleurs ce que disent tous les
candidats de gauche hier et ce matin
alors alexis quelle légitimité
finalement pour cette candidate de plus
sur quel programme
alors c'est bien là où le bât blesse
l'arrivée de christiane taubira à
quelques jours du premier tour de la
présidentielle on parle du mois d'avril
de début avril c'est un peu un chien
dans un jeu de qui s'est un peu trop
tard l'idée de cette primaire elle n'est
pas mauvaise en soi de dire qu'il faut
que il y ait une primaire populaire qui
est davantage de gens qui puissent voter
s'inscrire là on n'est qu'à quatre cent
mille c'était quand même d'avoir un
candidat issu des urnes et d'une
certaine union de la gauche déjà
d'unités or aujourd'hui on a une
candidate qui se prévalait de dire
surtout je ne suis pas candidate je ne
suis pas le messie je ne suis pas une
personne providentielle et la voix la
candidate qui va faire comme arnaud
montebourg appelé tous les candidats ce
matin arnaud montebourg lui a arrêté sa
campagne avant la primaire mais on
retrouve finalement la même dynamique
qu'il y à trois mois c'est à dire à
plusieurs comme de gauche dont certains
ont déjà fait une primaire c'est le cas
des écolos c'est le cas du parti
socialiste qui n'a pas fait primaire
mais qui a choisi anne hidalgo la france
a soumis ce qui avait fait le soutien
populaire de de nombreux militants pour
dire jean luc mélenchon est notre
candidat qui ne reconnaissent pas du
tout ce scrutin qui ont refusé
d'ailleurs d'y participer donc la
légitimité de christiane taubira c'est
celle tout simplement d'une candidate de
plus avec en plus se passer celle d'être
la ministre du gouvernement de françois
hollande d'avoir côtoyé emmanuel macron
de jugé que le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macro n'est pas si mauvais que ça il ya
bien sûr beaucoup de choses très
mauvaise mais aussi il ya des choses à
garder apparemment est un programme qui
aujourd'hui n'existe pas donc il en
quelques jours construire un programme
tout ça n'est pas sérieux pour beaucoup
de militants et pose la question de qui
va vouloir s'unir derrière les sept
candidatures de plus de christiane
taubira aujourd'hui personne n'a fait un
pas vers elle n'y a ni d anne hidalgo
qui continue qui compte bien aller
jusqu'au bout au moins ces déclarations
yannick jadot qui a dit qu'il n'y avait
aucune raison que cela change quoi que
ce soit et jean luc mélenchon qui parle
d'une primaire qui était faite pour elle
et qui à laquelle il avait refusé de
participer donc pour pour christiane
taubira une légitimité certes mais un
timing très mauvais et une dynamique qui
visiblement n'est pas là malgré sa
victoire d'hier alors que peut-il se
passer à gros chats présents alexis
rien la désunion la même et puis le
risque de voir des candidats cherchent
et l'union pour certains bien sûr
cherché aussi à exfiltrer anne hidalgo
qui je ne vois pas dans les conditions
actuelles pourrait finir sa campagne
dire voilà nous avons sauvé le soldat
parti socialiste nous avons sauvé en
quelque sorte la social démocratie en
faisant perdre un candidat de gauche qui
lui est haut dans les sondages et qui
ait said d'enclencher une dynamique
d'union se parle de jean luc mélenchon
avec l'université pardon le parlement
populaire l'union populaire lui aussi
utilisent populaire mais avec des
classes populaires là qui sont présents
puisque cette primaire populaire été
critiquée d'être très peu populaire en
termes de profil sociologique 1 on parle
de gens plutôt citadins plutôt jeunes
plutôt csp + issus de grandes écoles ce
qui n'est pas le cas bien sûr de
du parlement de l'union populaire donc
encore une cacophonie à gauche on a
l'impression que 2022 cette élection qui
arrive en avril va se jouer sans la
gauche qui est en train de faire une
primaire finalement beaucoup trop tard
avec des candidats qui ne savent plus
finalement comment faire campagne ou qui
font campagne de manière beaucoup trop
soft par rapport à l'enjeu sauf pour
certains aujourd'hui les sondages
d'ailleurs en attestent ses jean luc
mélenchon qui est loin devant pour ce
qui est des candidats de gauche et
yannick jadot qui essaye de remonter et
de dévoiler son programme cette semaine
merci beaucoup alexis l'édito politique
d'alexis poulin a retrouvé sur les
réseaux sociaux